la barre des consommateurs c'est
toujours de cette prime est plutôt de
bien lire et de bien s'informer vérifie
au moins qu'ils ont une assurance que
vous avez pas seulement aux numéros de
téléphone parce qu'un cellulaire après
son gîte la carte ici un problème vous
vous puissiez avoir des recours contre
ces gens là la journée commence et puis
ben on veut éviter que ça tourne au
cauchemar quand on déménage
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire des
fois on a des boîtes a terminé également
le matin là avant que le camion arrive
avec les déménageurs alors quand on peut
s'assurer que tout se passe bien on
joint à québec charles tanguay de
l'office de la protection du
consommateur bonjour monsieur tanguay
bonjour madame lacroix
je vois que vous avez des bois derrière
vous est ce que vous êtes vous-même en
déménagement aujourd'hui alors c'est pas
de mise en scène c'est effectivement le
cas je vais déménager dans les
prochaines heures
mais mon histoire s'arrête l'intérêt
pour mon histoire s'arrête là puisque
dans mon cas je déménage à deux portes
d'ici donc ce sera avec des proches à
l'huile de bras comme on dit oui oui
avec de la pizza donc genève ont
embauché de déménageur et on va parler
bien sûr du code ceux qui embauchent
plus déménageurs pour le faire
ben c'est ça exactement parce que vous
avez des conseils là vous avez publié un
communiqué avec plusieurs conseils à
donner à ceux qui déménagent aujourd'hui
allez-y avec le premier qui concerne en
fait d'avoir une entente bien précisant
avec les démineurs les déménageurs tout
à fait madame bonin de la cev le disais
dans l'extrait que il faut s'y prendre
d'avancé sur que si vous n'avez pas de
déménageur aujourd'hui vous allez
peut-être être mal pris donc on donne
nos conseils dès le mois de mars ou
avril pour dire aux gens de bié choisi
de faire un contrat écrit claire qui
précise toutes les modalités la chose à
dire ce matin c'est d'avoir ce
contrôleur sous la main et pas dans le
fond d'une boîte justement pour pouvoir
vous y référer si un problème
l'autre chose aussi c'est que si vous
avez des biens particulièrement précieux
ou que auquel vous tenir sur peuvent
être fragiles
il pourrait être bon de faire des photos
de ce qui est de ce qui vous apparaît
plus important en cas par exemple si le
bien était égaré aussi encore il était
endommagé les photos pourraient vous
aider dans un évent
le recours oui pour avoir des preuves là
aussi à perte vol six abris de ce que de
ce que les gens vont prendre pour nous
pour d'apporter d'un lieu à l'autre
au moins on aura des preuves à ce moment
là que vous proposez également là qu'on
s'assure du déroulement qu'on soit sur
place pendant que les gens sont là oui
tout à fait idéalement vous devriez
plusieurs personnes une personne au
point de départ une personne vous point
d'arrivée et s'il ya quelque chose qui
cloche
avoir une personne de vos proches qu'ils
puissent être témoin et qui pourra
éventuellement témoigner s'il ya lieu
dans le cas d'un litige éventuel
l'autre chose aussi c'est de s'assurer
que vous avez le le déroulement se fasse
selon l'horaire prévu
si vous avez un bon contrat il ya une
heure qui sera précisée or c'est souvent
le cas c'est qu'il ya tellement de
déménagement cette journée si ou les
jours qui précèdent ou qui suivent qu'
il ya une surchauffe de la demande et
que donc on peut arriver accumulé des
retards les déménageurs peuvent être en
retard
si votre déménageur est en retard et se
peut que l'autre déménageur qui
travaille pour ceux qui veulent entrer
chez vous soit pris lui aussi dans ce
retard les factures à ses clients des
heures supplémentaires dont vous
pourriez de tenues responsables donc il
peut y avoir un si dd recours comme ça
si le retard de votre déménagement vous
occasionnent des dommages à vous ou à
ceux qui veulent entrer chez vous puis
que vous n'êtes toujours pas sorti alors
c'est important de préciser leur bien
sûr et que l'horaire soit respectée
parce que c'était une chorégraphie il
faut sortir avant que l'actionnaire
qatar arrive mais là vous nous dites
qu'on peut même être tenu responsable du
montant qui sera sous facturés aux
locataires qui suit qui nous suit
c'est certain que si un camion puis 4,4
déménageur qui qui se tournent les
pouces en à votre chez vous parce que
vous n'êtes toujours pas sorti à cause
de votre propre des ménages ah oui il
peut y avoir des responsabilités qui
soit tu sois pas été du doigt il faut
vérifier également j'imagine
qu'on peut parfois se faire facturé des
montants qui n'était pas prévu à la base
par exemple alors là des miroirs ou des
téléviseurs parfois il y en a qui en
profite pour ajouter à la facture
effectivement bon serra le fils reçoit
quelques centaines de plaintes par année
contre d'aidé mais n'a jamais ça arrive
on ne souhaite pas que ça nous arrive le
jour même parce que effectivement il ya
une pression et ce qu'on voit c'est des
déménageurs inventent toutes sortes de
bonnes raisons pour vous facturez
quelques centaines devra de plus le jour
même et ça peut même aller dans certains
cas jusqu'à garder vos biens dans le
camion comme en otage jusqu'à ce que
vous acceptiez de les payer
en fait c'est sûr on essaie toujours de
s'entendre là c'est là où tu es moins
peut être très utile dans ces
discussions là et puis si si vraiment ça
ne fonctionne pas il vaut probablement
mieux payées immédiatement mais en
avisant déménageurs qu'on n'en restera
pas là et qu'on pourrait revenir contre
lui pour contester cette facture si bien
sûr l'entente était clair et qu'il y a
nettement sur facturations à ce
moment-là vous appelez à l'office dans
les jours qui suivent
et on va vous indiquer comment exercer
vos recours même chose s'il s'il ya des
biens qui sont endommagés ou qui
disparaissent à ce moment là mais vous
pouvez faire une réclamation au
déménageur ou à son assureur et par la
suite si ça ne règle pas porter plainte
éventuellement envoyé une mise en
demeure
et voilà qu'elle en espérant que toutes
ces choses n'arrivent pas non c'est ça
exactement
donc faut veiller au grain puis
effectivement espérer que tout se passe
bien en cours de journée
bien je vous souhaite un bon
déménagement charles tanguay merci nous
avons déménagé toutes ces boîtes la
merci au pays